كأس من النبيذ أو الجعة بعد العمل هي
طريقة شائعة جدًا للناس للاسترخاء في
دراسة جديدة نُشرت للتو ، على الرغم من أنها قد
تجعلك تفكر مرتين قبل
أن تنضم إلينا هذا الشراب الثاني الذي تنضم إلينا
الآن مع مقابلة المراسلة الطبية الدكتورة
تارا نارولا انتظر انتظر انتظر انتظر انتظر
انتظر  ماذا تنتظر ما الذي تديره
هنا ، هل تعرف مدى إرهاق
حياة الناس الآن ، حسنًا ، هذه هي
الصفقة لآلاف القرون التي
كنا نستهلك فيها ما
أطلق عليه الإغريق رحيق الآلهة ، لكن هذا
الرحيق قد يواجه مشاكل عندما ''  إعادة
شرب الكحول بإفراط ، لذا فإن ما نعرفه هو أن
الإفراط في تعاطي الكحول مرتبط
بزيادة معدلات الاعتلال والوفيات في
الواقع ، فهو سبب رئيسي يمكن الوقاية منه
للوفاة المبكرة ومعدلات الوفاة
لأسباب تعزى للكحول
قد ارتفعت على مدار العقد الماضي ، لذا
نظر الباحثون هنا  في
استهلاك الكحول من 2015 إلى 2019 في الولايات المتحدة
، ووجدوا أن واحدة من كل ثماني
حالات وفاة من بين 20 إلى 64
تُعزى إلى الإفراط في تناول الكحول
الكحول جيدة واحدة من كل خمس وفيات في أولئك الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين
20 و 49 تُعزى أيضًا إلى
الاستهلاك المفرط للكحول وكان
أعلى عند الرجال مقارنة بالنساء ، حيث تفاوت
عبر الولايات ، لذا فإن أعلى معدلات في ولاية نيو مكسيكو هي
الأدنى في ولاية ميسيسيبي بشكل عام ،
وكان الجنوب الشرقي لديه معدلات أقل والغرب
الأوسط العلوي الغربي  معدلات أعلى في نيو إنجلاند
وعندما نتحدث عن
هذه الأسباب ، فنحن نتحدث عن
حالات التسمم حوادث السيارات
بالسم ، فإننا نعني تعاطي المخدرات مع
حوادث السيارات
الكحوليّة وأمراض الكبد المرتبطة بالكحول
حيث ترتفع ثانية واحدة آسف  لم يكن مكانًا
أعلى مرة أخرى ، لذا فهو أعلى في
الغرب في الغرب الأوسط الأعلى ونيو إنجلاند
، كان الجنوب الشرقي يتمتع بخير منخفض ، لذا فإن
ما تتحدث عنه الاستخدام المفرط
ما هو ما يتم تحديده من خلال ما هو
الاستخدام المقبول الصحيح وهكذا هناك
الكثير من الجدل حولك يعرف هل من
الآمن الشرب على الإطلاق ، وفي الحقيقة
ليس هناك الكثير مما نسميه
التجارب العشوائية المضبوطة حول هذا
الموضوع ولكن ما نسميه  بشكل عام نقول أنه
إذا كنت تشرب باعتدال فهذا
تقنيًا بالنسبة للكثيرين يعتبر
آمنًا وبالمعتدل فلنتحدث عن ذلك فنحن
نتحدث عن كوب واحد على الأكثر يوميًا
للنساء كأسين في اليوم للرجال
وعندما نتحدث عن الأنواع
حوالي 12 أوقية من البيرة ، و 5 أوقية من النبيذ
، وأوقية ونصف من المشروبات الكحولية القوية الآن ،
هناك بعض الارتباط مع
الشرب المعتدل وخطر أقل للإصابة
بأمراض القلب والأوعية الدموية ، من ناحية أخرى ،
عليك أن تزن ذلك مع خطر الإصابة بالسرطان
ونحن نعلم أنه هناك  يزيد
من خطر الإصابة بالسرطان ، لذلك هناك بعض
الجدل هناك ، فنحن بالتأكيد لا نطلب من
الناس البدء في الشرب إذا لم
يشربوا ، ولكن إذا حافظت على هذا
المستوى المعتدل ، فربما يكون الأمر
مثيرًا للاهتمام لأن لدينا مثل هذا
القبول الطبيعي  الكحول في
مجتمعنا وعلاقتنا به
وربما نحتاج إلى إعادة التفكير في أننا
بدأنا تعلم عندما أصبحت الماريجوانا
أكثر قبولًا وأكثر شيوعًا
ويبدو أن فوائد شهر مايو  كن
معتدلاً قد يكون استخدام الماريجوانا أفضل
من تعاطي الكحول المعتدل أعتقد
أننا بحاجة إلى البدء في التفكير في الأشياء
لنكون مدركين لعدد الأشخاص ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك الطبيب
يقدر ذلك
أجنبي